smooth endoplasmic reticulum is a
membrane-bound system that lacks
ribosome which differentiate its from
the rough endoplasmic reticulum smooth
endoplasmic reticulum plays diverse
functions like lipid synthesis drug
detoxification calcium storage
carbohydrate metabolism and even steroid
hormone synthesis
an enzyme known as cytochrome p450 helps
in detoxification of drugs and
xenobiotics
then the membrane phospholipid synthesis
happens in the smooth endoplasmic
reticulum
the rate limiting enzyme is present in
the ER membrane
the cholesterol biosynthesis pathway
also takes place in the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum
hmg-coa reductase the rate limiting
enzyme is present in ACR membrane
and thereby ACR plays diverse role in
terms of cellular function watch the
full video to know more